situations the result is the most
important thing black is simply going to
pre-move his bishop back and forth back
and forth
um here you can gain time on the clock
you can gain these three seconds after
every move just by repeating repeatedly
moving your bishop and you can still
make that pawn break breakthrough
do you want to win this game ivanka
yes
but okay magnus is considering it he's
done it he's done it so he's playing for
the win okay
okay let's see whether this gamble play
pays off yeah so he's taking some small
risks here magnus carlsen but it's
limited risk so he's giving back a pawn
he was a pawn up he's giving it away in
order to create a path in for the black
king
so maybe a bit of psychological warfare
here he's just saying to maxine vasily
grav okay i don't even want to draw i
want to win this one
okay here we're going for the draw now
the bishops are just going back and
forth a bit of yoyo effect and it's a
draw magnus takes the win in today's
match wow impressive stuff by magnus
carlsen and the blitz thai breaks he is
the winner of the